tomb raider is now the third feature
film adaptation of Square Enix's game
series this time round Lara Croft is
portrayed by Alicia vikander no longer
Angelina Jolie of the original first two
films and she's the heir to the Croft
family her father has been missing for
quite some time and she's very
independent she doesn't feel the need to
take any of this money but once she
uncovers some truths about her father in
a possible location where he may have
gone missing she sets out on her very
first adventure to find him this one was
very much so based on the 2013 reboot
game and it follows it very closely and
many visual elements from that game
carry over to this film including
tiptoeing across a plane that's stuck in
a waterfall or tiptoeing across a tree
that's fallen over a cliff surviving a
lot of Falls even certain wounds that
she gets are straight out of the game
when she comes face to face with danger
and a life-threatening situation in
which she has to make a terrible choice
it plays out similarly to the way the
game did and in that way this is one of
the most visually faithful video game
adaptations ever made as far as the
puzzles she solves the way she obtains
her weaponry whether she's using a bow
and arrow or something else it's exactly
like in the reboot game and so if you
were a fan of that game which I was
you're going to be happy as you see it
faithfully translated to this screen
this film was directed by a norwegian
filmmaker named roar who thug and i made
up said his name completely incorrectly
and with him he's brought a good sense
of momentum he understands the important
stepping stones that have to be present
to set up Lara Croft as the Tomb Raider
we know her to be and all of the things
that have to happen for that development
to make sense her first adventure her
first kill her first wound that she has
to dress all of these things are set up
fairly well and that's my biggest
takeaway as a positive from this movie
is the character of Lara Croft has never
been portrayed in a film more
realistically and better to be honest
I'm a big fan of Angelina Jolie's movies
but not in the sense that they are great
films if you've seen my review of Tomb
Raider
know that it's one of my biggest guilty
pleasures of all time I could watch that
movie with friends and family over and
over again and it never gets old it's so
silly and absolutely hilarious I enjoy
that film quite a bit but Alicia
vikander is really damn good in this
movie she honors this character so well
and whether or not fans end up liking
this movie or not I think the majority
will walk away happy with the portrayal
of Croft on the big screen as someone
who is a fan of the games who has played
most of them I was happy with this
adaptation I think that it has a few
issues storytelling wise and it has some
physics problems that really all of the
Tomb Raider games have if you want to
take them seriously Lara Croft survives
so much I mean she's thrown through
trees she falls down waterfalls I mean
she really should be dead and split into
a million pieces but it's one of those
things where you either roll with it or
you don't
there's physics on display in this movie
that don't always make sense characters
survive things that don't always make
sense but as a video game adaptation
it's sort of something you expect to
happen even in superhero films people
walk away from things and you're like no
I'm sorry you're you're a human you're
not a superhero and you should be dead
and that happens a lot in this movie and
there's quite a bit of exposition as
well a lot of storytelling a lot of
people are telling stories about things
that happen in the past with ancient
evils and there's a revelation towards
the third act that got kind of silly
when you uncover what this ancient evil
is really about it does seem pretty
far-fetched but I must reiterate this is
a Tomb Raider film all of the Tomb
Raider games have an edge of unbelievab
ility to them in every sense the 90s
games were considerably more sexualized
than the reboot was lara croft was more
of an object in those games and angelina
jolie's films followed more in the
footsteps of the 90s Tomb Raider with
more tongue-in-cheek elements and a lot
more sexiness in fact I've always said
that the first Tomb Raider movie is the
last 90s movie ever made because that
was one of the very last big studio
action movies that came out before 9/11
that was incredibly silly and
over-the-top and after 9/11 happen
action movies got a lot more serious and
more realistic so in the case of this
film following off the foot
of the more grounded reboot Tomb Raider
that we have today I think they did a
pretty good job accomplishing and
putting that vibe in that world on the
big screen
I think Tomb Raider fans will mostly be
happy I know I am it's not a great film
by any means it has a lot of silly
elements and for the most part it's just
a fun action thriller you can watch and
as a video game adaptation it's
definitely one of the better ones but
don't expect an amazing groundbreaking
experience that's gonna change your life
this is Tomb Raider and I think they did
a pretty good job of capturing the
character I'm gonna give Tomb Raider a
beat guys thank you so much as always
for watching I would like to review the
Cradle of Life soon I'll try to get to
it when I get some other reviews out of
the way as always guys are the best
thank you very much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes
[Music]